[Music]
breaking news a star-studded event at
the level Hotel in Los Angeles has been
taken over by armed gunmen we now go to
a live feed from the assailants and can
confirm that one of the hostages is
international pop star
shaggy yeah he's happening see wasn't me
singing it shaggy
honey came in and she caught me
red-handed creeping with a girl next
door
picture this we were both butt-naked and
now destined for how do I get that I
have given a extra key I think we should
what's with the pockets I'm showing them
I'm unarmed
we can take them my name is Alex but
three exes I want to go explosive on
these [ __ ] 3x means poison by
the way it's also a Vin Diesel movie
let's [ __ ] some [ __ ] up
SWAT new fields transporters
what are you doing up there oh thank god
the hell are you doing they're here to
help us but not get a little cooler [ __ ]
getting saved by the LAPD didn't listen
to Kendrick Lamar loves me I'll get me
if I followed a loser like you around
for years guys stop you just shot at me
I shot near you [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]